British billionaire Richard Branson has big
plans for the Colombian border town of Cucuta.
He says his goal is to raise money for food
and medical supplies AND ultimately get it
accross the border to Venezuela.
Meanwhile everyday struggle for locals goes
on.
Many cross the border here regularly to pick
up desperately needed supplies.
They are hoping to see change soon.
"We want to be free.
We want to be able to cross the border, we
want freedom, we want the government to fall.
It is what we all want.
And elections so we can have a new president."
Some however have lost all hope and are taking
extreme measures -- describing how it feels
to be leaving their country for good.
"Right now I'm sad... this is degrading for
a human being.
Very degrading."
President Nicolas Maduro is also taking exteme
measures.
He sees any attempt to bring in aid as a pretext
for military intervention.
On Thursday he closed the country's border
with Brazil -- and said that he was also considering
closing the frontier with Colombia.
"A complete closure of the border with Colombia,
I'm considering that.
If it's best for a man to be prepared, it's
even better for a nation to be prepared."
That could make things tricky for Opposition
leader and self proclaimed President Juan
Guaido.
He left his home in Caracas on Thursday to
make the 800 km journey to the Colombian border.
He and thousands of his supporters are promising
to bring US aid into the country, but he has
not explained how they plan to do it.
Meanwhile back at the border just accross
the river from Cucuta, President Maduro is
organising his own concert on
Venezuelan soil.